is the silent majority real we always
hear about the silent majority the
silent majority is going to come up
well is there really a silent majority
let's not forget america elected obama
twice
we elected bill clinton we elected jimmy
carter there
sometimes the silent majority doesn't
quite work out so
is there one now president trump seems
to think so
his campaign seems to think so and they
have just
premised an excellent new campaign ad
on the silent majority i'll have to
narrate it because it's silent
i'm a mother of four this woman woman of
color says joe biden worries me he's
weak
biden embraced the policies of the far
left biden will raise taxes she just
throws the cards to the side
give amnesty to 11 million illegal
immigrants biden's trade deals
emptied our factories huge emptied i'm
afraid to say this
out loud i won't risk my children's
future
with biden and that's the money line i'm
afraid
to say this out loud she's
a woman of color that's the i guess
that's the new category right what the
left likes to say
is when we say silent majority we're
just talking about white men and white
men are terrible and forget about them
no the silent majority includes people
of every color of every shape every
gender there's only two but every single
gender
the silent majority is it real and will
it win it for trump in november
we'll get into the specifics i'm michael
knowles that's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we have got to
get to
a superb comment that came up yesterday
on youtube from dana
nice of obama to mention closing polling
stations
my democratic governor closed six in my
district
due to covid exactly this is the point
during barack obama's highly politicized
eulogy for john lewis he talked about
how republicans are trying to steal the
vote well who's trying to steal the vote
who's trying to steal the election
sure looks to me like it's democrats who
are trying to cancel the campaign
cancel debates and cancel voting as well
this is the issue of the silent majority
or maybe the silenced
majority which we will analyze in just
one moment first though
speaking of safety got to thank our
friends over at ring you know rings
mission
make neighborhoods safer and not only do
they do that
that's wonderful i feel nice and safe
and secure knowing that even though
elise is a pretty good shot
one can check in on one's own home from
the bedroom
from the office from whether you're on a
beach halfway across the world
you can check in you can feel safe a lot
of people get in packages these days
maybe you don't know who's dropping them
off it just allows you that peace of
mind
but more than that more importantly for
me i give ring to my friends as a
housewarming present
ring is not only cool not only does it
make you feel safe not only is it like
you're living in the future
it's inexpensive as well so you seem
like a really cool guy when you give it
to your friends as a gift right now get
a special offer on a ring welcome kit
when you go to ring.com
knowles can a w-l-e-s that includes the
ring video doorbell 3
and chime pro it is all you need to
start building
custom security for your home today
we all want to make sure that we are
safe particularly these days
things are pretty crazy out there head
on over ring dot com slash knowledge can
wles ring.com
slash knowles so is there a silent
majority
i've had long debates and arguments with
conservatives over this because
some people want to say that there's no
such thing as the silent majority
even in 2016 or 2020 because more people
voted for hillary
than voted for trump which is true right
hillary won the popular vote
who knows how many dead people in
illinois jumped out of their graves to
vote for hillary
but let's just take the numbers on the
surface more people
voted for hillary does that mean that
there's not a silent majority
no that's a different issue
we know for a fact there is a silent or
i think it's better to say
silenced majority of americans who feel
that they can't
speak plainly who can't speak truthfully
because of political correctness we
talked yesterday on the show
about how progressivism works outside of
the realm of traditional politics right
progressivism because they turn
everything into a science it's all
pseudoscience but it's all a science
so they tell you you can't go to church
based on science they tell you you can't
go to school based on science
they tell you you can't do this and you
can't do that based on science they tell
you
that boys can use the girls room based
on science it's just obviously
ridiculous but what they want to do is
take issues that are properly in the
realm of political debate
taken up by we the people they want to
take that out of the realm of debate and
put it into the hands of the lab coats
the enforcement mechanism for
progressivism
is political correctness it's this
mealy-mouthed
crazy system of euphemisms that silences
people
twists their own thought and makes
perfectly plain things
unspeakable it's not just conservatives
do you remember the people who were
complaining about political correctness
back in the 90s and early 2000s a lot of
them were kind of liberal in fact a lot
of them still are
kind of liberal they're old school
liberals or they're moderate people who
maybe they don't think that much about
politics but they know they don't like
having to pretend that a man is a woman
they don't want to pretend that a baby's
not a baby they don't want to have to
pretend like america is the worst place
that ever existed
these are normal people but they're not
necessarily going to vote
for republicans okay a lot of people
are fed up the question about the silent
majority is is the silent majority
going to vote in november for
republicans
are they all going to break for trump
i'll give you a perfect example of this
came out of the nba now you'll be
shocked to hear i don't know very much
about the nba
i don't follow the league particularly
closely however
actually the only sport i ever followed
closely was baseball and now i can't do
that
because they disrespect the national
anthem but i looked a little bit into
the nba
have you ever heard of a player for the
orlando magic named jonathan
isaac something tells me that
even if you are a basketball fan you
might not know who that guy
is the reason that i mention him
is because as of right now he is selling
more
jerseys than anybody in the nba other
than lebron james
how's that possible well the reason is
jonathan isaac is the only guy on his
team
who had the colioni to stand up for the
national anthem
he stands up for the national anthem all
the other players kneel
the whole league kneels down they accept
the premises of the radical left's black
lives matter they attack
the national anthem the symbol of our
country
they did that presumably because they
thought that's what everybody wanted to
see that's that's where the mass the
majority of people were right wrong
the one guy who stands up his jersey
sales go through the roof even though
very few people have heard of him
why because they're it now
look obviously there's the silent
majority are all these nba fans going to
vote for
donald trump i don't know i don't and
i'm not i'm not even saying this
just because the nba has a
disproportionately black
audience and black voters
disproportionately don't like donald
trump right i'm not doing
what the left does and divvying this
down strictly on the basis of race
but i'm thinking of sports in general a
lot of people who watch sports
have sports you know people who don't
watch sports treat politics as sports
that's kind of what we do
but people who watch sports very often
they're just not that politically
involved so are they going to vote for
trump are they going to vote for biden
because they're not paying attention are
they not going to vote at all
that's the question what we do know
though is trump's got to get those guys
trump's got to get the guys who are
buying the jerseys of jonathan
isaac okay and the one way to do that
is not just to show what trump has done
and what trump's going to do they've got
to show who biden is and not just who
biden was 50 years ago
or 500 years ago when he started in
american politics before america even
existed
you got to show who joe biden is now
because joe biden is not that old
nice lovable moderate uncle joe that we
all
think that we remember joe biden is
talking
like any radical leftist you'd meet on
the street in fact
in a recent campaign podcast i can't
believe this isn't coming out until now
it was breitbart dug this up campaign
podcast may 11th
joe biden is interviewing andrew yang he
calls for
outright revolution i think we can
get through this period but the things
we have to change
and i think i know you agree um
we need some revolutionary institutional
changes in how we do things
yes amen it's painful because every
passing day
more and more americans are hitting
desperate circumstances and dire straits
uh and they're feeling this inability to
be more agile every single day well we
need an environment in the wake of this
revolution everybody has a
chance to be part of the mix and so it's
not so self-evident exactly how to do
that
so it's not just a typical joe faux pie
a gaff he says a word that he didn't
mean he repeats that word
multiple times you hear revolution
revolution
this has been a term of art on the left
since at least woodrow wilson right
going back
all the way to the progressive era but
it's
it's taken on renewed vigor particularly
in the obama administration when obama
said he wants to fundamentally transform
america well joe biden
was barack obama's vp and now he's using
the same language i think if most people
heard that
in the wake of george washington statues
falling down and cities going up in
flames
and murder rates going up by 175 and
shooting rates going through the roof
i think if people heard that
revolutionary change
they wouldn't be so gung-ho to go out
and vote for joe and i think joe biden's
campaign
agrees with that i think democrats agree
with that and so what they're trying to
do is hide the candidate away
in particular they're trying to get out
of the debates so so right now this
question
should biden debate trump well it's very
simple
no if you're joe biden if you want
biden to win then you should absolutely
pray
that joe biden does not debate trump yes
joe biden has lost a step and even
before he lost a step he didn't have
much step to lose to begin with
he's always been a doofus i'm sorry to
say it there's no other way to put it
he's been a liar he's been a plagiarist
he graduated at the bottom of his
unimpressive class
he messes up words he's an empty suit
that's all the guy's ever been
and now he's an empty suit who doesn't
even remember he's an empty suit so it
wouldn't have gone well even in the best
days it certainly
doesn't look like it'll go well now and
that's why huge democrats are saying
don't debate joe lockhart former clinton
press secretary and cnn
tells biden whatever you do
don't debate trump
and then the way he the way he justifies
this he says trump he
he tells a lot of lies trump has made
more than 20 000 misleading or false
statements
according to the washington post by the
way there it is again there's that
trying to make politics a scientific
pursuit
they're going to quantify every lie that
donald trump has ever told
then you look into the lies because i
can't really name big lies that trump is
told
when i think of obama lying i think if
you like your doctor you can keep your
doctor it's a pretty big lie it's a
significant lie
but with trump it's every little one
that's like i had breakfast this morning
fact check seven pinocchios trump only
had coffee this morning you know or
or my my crowd size was 30 000. fact
check
2 million pinocchios his crowd size was
only 29
400. you say okay i guess that's a lie
right but but that's what the left tries
to do
so he says trump has told all these lies
it's a fool's errand
to enter the ring with someone who can't
follow the rules or the truth don't
forget joe biden dropped out of his
first presidential race
because he lied explicitly and
importantly
not just about his academic record but
he plagiarized other people's speeches
so if anybody knows about lies it's joe
biden
but but also if you're if you're getting
into the ring with somebody who lies
that's great for you
because then you can refute those lies
right but no no one thinks joe can do it
zach petkanus former hillary clinton
senior adviser writes on twitter last
week
that biden can skip the debates because
trump is not a legitimate candidate
that's another left-wing trick
because for the progressives there is no
way they can lose the left can't lose
because theirs is the scientifically
correct
capital h historical path into the
future so if they lose
it's got to be illegitimate and this
this fella
zac petkanus from hillary's team is just
buying into that
as we win tails you lose right there's
no way for a republican legitimately to
win an election so
why do we even need to debate them why
do we even need the facade of democracy
and then thomas friedman one of my
favorite lefties over there at the new
york times
suggests that that biden only debate
trump if trump releases his tax returns
what do tax returns have to do with
debates
i have no idea but what he's saying is
basically get a concession out of trump
because you joe biden are going to lose
the debates so is he going to debate or
is he not going to debate
biden campaign senior adviser corrine
jean-pierre
says that he will debate but there's a
catch
he's only going to debate when it's very
very close to the election and with
mail-in voting by the way
with mail-in voting many votes will
already be cast
before joe biden has to say two words
well the bind campaign has been
very clear crystal clear on this is that
we have
we have said yes to doing three three
debates
and one vice presidential debate as it's
been laid out by the non-partisan
uh debate commission a debate commission
that's been around and
other campaigns have followed for
generations every campaign has followed
for generation and that is where we have
we have agreed to do and look what's
happening is donald trump and his
campaign are trying to
move the goal post but joe biden has
said from
time and time again the first time he
was asked the question in the couple
times after that he is ready to take on
donald trump
we will be there he will be there ready
to go
and so the question is will donald trump
be
yeah i think donald trump will be ready
to go the problem is the debates are
going to start after 16 states are
already voting
and you see the left is desperate to
convince people
to mail in their votes why well because
we know it's much easier to commit voter
fraud if you mail it in
than it is otherwise and don't forget
the left the left owns all of these
mainstream institutions including
the administrative government so they've
got a better chance to steal the
election there but the other reason is
very simple
if you're not going to have a debate
until september 29th for your first ever
debate
you can already harvest a lot of votes
for biden before they realize the guy
can't
can't pronounce his own name the trump
campaign should have caught this sooner
they should have caught this months ago
and it is
it's on the trump campaign that months
ago they didn't catch this
things happen in campaigns you dropped
the ball they shouldn't have dropped
that ball okay we've talked about how
for the past few months the trump
campaign
did not seem to be going in the right
direction they seem to be steering the
ship in the right direction now but
this is a big faux pas because as we've
said from the beginning covid
is the campaign for the democrats
they're trying to hide their candidate
in a bunker we were saying a year ago
that joe biden's best chance
is to run a front porch campaign and
never leave and then somehow
coincidentally that seems to be working
out for him so they should have moved
those debates up right now conservatives
are always
always behind the ball on this kind of
stuff
we keep playing by rules
as if the other side is going to play by
those rules
we keep honoring traditions as if the
other side is going to honor those
traditions
we keep playing as though this is
a game where we all agree on the basics
we all love america we all want what's
best for america
we all want to live up to the most
wonderful ideals
of our history and our foundations
and that's just not the case that is not
the case
you saw it at john lewis's funeral
yesterday we played the clip
of george bush saying look john and i
didn't always agree
and john also didn't think i was a
legitimate president and boycotted my
inauguration
look we didn't always agree but in our
america the america we fight for
we can have those disagreements but we
still we're still
you know countrymen and then obama gets
up there and says
republicans are racists and they're
george wallace and they're trying to
take away your right to vote and they
hate you
vote for democrats you have to go vote
for democrats right now those are not
the same thing
okay and and the right conservatives
need to wake up for this there's another
debate coming out right now not just is
there a silent majority
not just should joe biden debate there's
another debate going on which is
if god forbid there is a supreme court
vacancy
that comes up we don't know who but
certainly there could be a few
maybe one in particular if there were a
supreme court vacancy that came up
before the election
should the republicans fill it the
correct answer to that question
is duh yeah of course we should fill it
we have the senate we have the president
yeah put push the push the person
through
but some conservatives say no that would
be wrong why would that be wrong because
you see
in 2016 when antonin scalia died
barack obama put up a man a wonderful
man a man
one of the most wonderful jurists ever
merrick garland
peace be upon him and merrick garland
was not taken up for confirmation
by the senate and he was not taken up
because it was an election year and we
established this principle and now it's
an election year again
and give me a break give me a break
in 2016 the democrats were saying you
had to ram merrick garland through
this is very awkward for them now that
joe biden is their nominee because the
last time there was a similar situation
in the early 1990s
joe biden said that absolutely the
president should not try to put
a candidate through when it was flipped
when the republicans had the presidency
and the democrats had the senate
and now it's going to be a little
different story again
there is nothing unprincipled about
using
your legal constitutional political
power
when you have it what does it mean to be
a conservative does does being a
conservative mean
that we have to play by a sort of rule
that we kind of half articulated four
years ago
as we were getting a supreme court
justice through that's what that's what
it means that's the height of being a
conservative no
being a conservative is conserving
things so
yeah if we have this one shot before
democrats
get rid of the filibuster make dc estate
make puerto rico a state
basically cut us off from having a
senate majority ever again yeah i think
it would be a good idea to get a supreme
court justice through
conservatives need to be willing
to exercise their power right now
mcconnell's saying of course he would
fill it
because cocaine mitch doesn't play
around on things like that lisa
murkowski is a little bit more moderate
in alaska she says
that it would be a double standard and
then daniel goldberg was a legal
director for some left-wing advocacy
advocacy group
alliance for justice action says it
would be outrageous to go back on their
purported principles
here's my principles we need a safe
country
we need a just country we need a free
country we should live up to our
greatest traditions we should we should
support and
enjoy and cherish our past and we should
look forward with hope to the future
those are my principles some
conservatives want to make up a whole
bunch of new principles
like you can you can never have
trade deals that include protection for
american workers that's it that's the
hill we're going to die on
or you have to play by the rules that
democrats said five years ago
or no that's not it it's much simpler
than that
and when you're talking about the silent
majority or the silenced majority
when you're talking about those people
they're not the ones with their noses
in the political philosophy books
they're not the ones reading the
manifestos
they want basic things keep me safe
let me go to work let me raise my family
don't tell me my son is a little girl
don't pretend that babies aren't babies
often
right at least there are a lot of a lot
of people in so maybe they don't even
care that much about that issue
let me have a safe just free
country that's what we got to do and
there there are things that we can do
to push that forward but we've got to
break
the locks of of political stasis that
we've had
for the past 30 years you can see the
consequences
of not standing up all around us a
republican
uh state senator in minnesota a senator
named warren limmer
just found this out the hard way when a
leftist mob came
knocking down the door to his house
we'll get to that in one second first
though
i've got to thank you i've got to thank
all of you
who have subscribed to the michael knoll
show on youtube not just the daily wire
youtube channel
which that's great we like giving ben
the views okay we like keeping the daily
wireship afloat
on our backs single-handedly but we also
like it when you head on over to the
michael mill show channel we really
appreciate it
we're right now i think we're about to
hit 200 000 so that's really great
thanks for ringing the bell
also you know we have the all-access
membership tier at daily wire this is
our highest level of membership you get
behind the scenes access to the hosts
and the writers and special guests
also you get early access to daily wire
products
like our new limited count collectors
edition baseball bat in collaboration
with pillbox
bat company best part about this
handcrafted here in the united states
emblazoned with the daily wire logo this
run of bats will be engraved
with the individual number in the order
they're produced from 1
to 100 so go get that very very cool
product only available to our all access
membership tier text the word baseball
to 83
400 to purchase your collector's edition
bat
and get 20 off all access right now with
coupon code access so text baseball to
84
300 and coupon code access and by the
way go check out
jeremy boring the god king jeremy boring
in absolute delight
doing an all-access as that spacex
landed down
me i don't care that much about outer
space but jeremy loves it so go listen
to that he knows a thing or two about it
head on over we'll be right back with a
lot more
republican state senator warren limmer
found out the hard way
what happens when a conservative
movement for
several decades doesn't stand up and
conserve much
of anything is you get roving gangs of
anarchists
banging down the doors so much for our
constitutional norms
take a listen if you want to be voted in
again
you will come and talk to us otherwise
you will never run in office again
he's definitely not interested the
banging continues
followed by howling obviously these
people have no right
to go to this man's house where his
family sleeps and bang on their door and
bang on other instruments with a whole
mob and threaten him and tell him to
come outside
that is the degradation of our
constitutional norms
would you ever see a right wing gang do
that no you wouldn't
imagine imagine if the tea party ever
did that
the tea party was the best behaved
popular movement
in american history they would show up
to places for rallies
they would leave the areas were cleaner
than before the tea party got there
and they were called violent maybe you
don't remember you know the the media
memory all these things the cycles so
fast
they were called violent they were
called nazis they were called
klansmen they were gonna they were a
threat they were gonna kill people they
were
so well behaved they were like boy
scouts
then blm and antifa show up
and burn down the country they're
peaceful protesters they're wonderful
peaceful protesters and by the way if
you don't support them
if you don't post the black square if
you don't post the blm hashtag
if you don't go to the blm mandatory
training session
for why you're a terrible awful person
and we need to give a lot of money to
self-described marxists if you don't go
to that you can have your life destroyed
probably better for you just to remain
silent
there's a lot of people right now who
feel that way
which way are they going to break part
of this
is the president needs to show strong
leadership kovid is the campaign for
democrats
they have exploited this thing to
hide all of the flaws of their candidate
to hide all of the flaws
of the election season where they would
probably get blown out
to hide all of the wonderful
accomplishments of the trump economy
we have got to be able to push back
against that so how do we do it
one way that people are being silenced
very literally is they're now being
mandated to put masks across their face
some conservatives they're okay with the
masks they say oh what's the big deal
the big deal is this there is no
evidence
that the masks do much of anything at
all
to stop the spread of this virus
none zilch nada
right now you've got public health
officials in sweden and the netherlands
saying this saying the masks are
pointless
they do nothing sweden's covid cases are
continuing to drop by the way remember
sweden it was the shame of all of the
west sweden
the whole population is going to get
decimated because sweden didn't lock
down
guess what sweden's doing better now
than virtually anybody
certainly any of their neighbors so the
country's top epidemiologist
in ender's tegnal don't you love those
scandinavian names
ender's tegnal says he sees no point
to mandating masks in public sweden's
death rate right now is lower than
italy's the netherlands same thing they
announced they would not
institute a face mask mandate why well
according to the
minister for medical care tamara van aak
it is because quote from a medical
perspective there is no proven
effectiveness
of masks the cabinet has decided that
there will be no national obligation
for wearing non-medical masks i've
mentioned this to people and
the honest leftists when i say there's
no evidence that the masks work they say
well you haven't proven that the masks
don't work
let me let me go back there you're
saying that we need to mandate
that everybody around the country wears
a very uncomfortable stupid ugly thing
on their faces
everywhere they every time they leave
the house because
i haven't proven that they
they don't have to i because i haven't
proven
that that they don't work prove to me
they do it i think it's you i think it's
you the people who want to institute
this massive national change
who need to prove to me that it does
anything and obviously there's no
evidence whatsoever
now some people might say well there was
one study once that showed that if you
take a hot glue gun and you glue the
mask to your face perfectly
and you wrap your whole head in saran
wrap then maybe particles won't get in
uh okay is that ever going to work in
public
see what the left will do is they'll
point to one example and they'll see
when things are working exactly
perfectly as i have ordered everybody to
make them work
then it works out great socialism
is perfect if everybody does exactly
what i tell them to do
then then the economy runs efficiently
it's perfect it works great but what
about reality
true socialism has never been tried true
social distancing has never been tried
what these two two public health
officials realized is even beyond the
efficacy of masks
people aren't going to wear them
appropriately they're not going to
launder them every time they wear them
or throw them at every time
they're not going to apply them exactly
perfectly without touching their face
they're not going to make them fit
exactly right without any spaces
people are people if your system doesn't
account for people being people
then your system's not going to work and
if it's not going to work what's the
point same thing with the lockdowns by
the way the point of the lockdowns was
slow the spread get the curve below the
maximum so we don't overwhelm the
hospitals
we never came close to overwhelming the
hospitals flattening the
flattening the curve is what we did it
worked out fine
now what now we're told wait for a
vaccine find a cure okay well we were
told by dr faucio get a vaccine which
will be 70 effective if we are
extraordinarily lucky
but then not everyone's going to get the
vaccine so we're not going to get to
hurt immunity so what are we doing
i get it in your in your wonderful
magical model
this is all working out perfectly but
here in reality it's not
and people are being silenced they're
being bullied they're being intimidated
they're being denied basic legal rights
they're being denied their right to go
to church for goodness sake they're
being denied their right to speak
because of your fantasies because of
your delusions
because you're flexing your power a lot
of people feel that way
and i don't think all of those people
are you know the
brooks brothers tie-wearing republican
types it is incumbent on conservatives
and republicans
to go get those people this brings us to
a question on covid aid so right now the
white house is threatening
to go go alone on more covid aid
democrats proposed a three trillion
dollar plan that's on top of the last
two trillion dollar plan that got
levered up to six trillion dollars for
to get us through what four months
of coronavirus and it didn't even get us
through that much now they want another
plan for three trillion dollars who
knows how much that would be levered up
to
republicans came back they said they
want a one trillion dollar plan they
can't
figure it out negotiations have stalled
white house says it might go it alone
and this is being called tyranny
irresponsible by
people on the left and the right i don't
like the idea of another
stimulus i think we need to reopen the
country
it's the only way forward but let's say
we can't do that let's say the left
won't let us reopen the country should
should the white house spend a trillion
dollars if they even can
in an election year you're damn right
they should of course they should first
of all
what's a trillion dollars between
friends right look at what our national
debt is well over 20 trillion dollars
look at the spending that we've had for
the last 50 years a trillion dollars
during a pandemic isn't going to matter
one little bit
but what the left is banking on is that
republicans won't spend that kind of
money
and won't get people through and then
we'll lose the election what the left is
banking on is they can successfully keep
the economy crashed
past november 3rd there are even school
districts now that are saying we plan to
reopen
the monday after election day it's all
about
the election so should republicans fight
back of course
is that unprincipled i don't think it's
unprincipled i would much rather have
good conservative governance
that make structural changes to pay down
our debt
and reduce our deficit i would rather
our government have some energy to it
and actually exert power
on the rare occasion that it has it
because the left sure is
bill de blasio was just asked how it
came to be the case
that he painted a giant black lives
matter mural down the streets of new
york
because if you want a mural in new york
city
there's a process to go through for that
so a reporter just recently asked
the bolshevik mayor of new york what
process he went through to put that
to put that mural up and you know what
he said he said he didn't go through a
process
because you know this this moment
suspends all the rules
of politics we haven't said no to people
who said if you want to apply you can
apply but there's a process
uh look the fact is that
what i decided to do with the black
lives matter
murals and this came out of a meeting at
gracie mansion weeks ago with
community leaders and activists who said
this would be such an important thing
for this city to declare
officially that is something again
transcends all normal realities because
we are in a moment of history where this
had to be said and done that's a
decision i made
but the normal process continues for
anyone who wants to apply
the normal process continues for all the
peasants
yeah the normal process is for all you
little people not for me i do whatever i
want
because this moment transcends all
political questions meaning it
transcends all of the law
all of the constitution this moment
it needed to be said right now by the
city of new york
that black lives matter let me ask you a
question
does anybody on planet earth think that
new york city does not believe that
black lives matter
no i think we all know that new york
city thinks black lives matter
if the mayor is right in his ridiculous
political view that real liberals love
black people and conservatives hate
black people
new york's one of the most liberal
places in the in the world
so you're good right any any way you
slice it
by de blasio's own logic he would be
fine but he's just another petty
progressive demagogue
who believes that the democratic order
the rule of law is fine it's a fine
facade for all you know all the ruffians
to kind of keep them amused and
distracted
but him he knows what's best he knows
that he gets to violate
the law he goes it alone that's what
happens here
that's what you can be promised more of
if joe biden is elected
an outright revolution he says and if
you thought the abuses of the obama
administration were bad
that was a long time ago now barack
obama got elected for the first time
a dozen years ago think about how
much more radical our politics of
politics rather have become in the last
few years
think about how much more radical
they've become in the last 12. barack
obama ran
against gay marriage he said marriage is
a bond between a man and a woman could
you imagine that now he seems like he's
an old fogey now that would make him a
conservative republican if he were to
say that now even many republicans won't
won't acknowledge that so what will you
get
with biden and meanwhile
you've got a full-on media
political journalist big tech apparatus
that will lie on the left's behalf what
started all of the blm
protests and riots it was the death of
george floyd
and we saw that video of the death of
george floyd and everybody was was
aghast looking at that video because you
see a man lying dead on the ground
well the daily mail somehow has gotten
footage of the body cam
leading up to the arrest and
to the eventual knee on his neck
i'm not going to play it i thought about
should i play it or should i not
i think there's something a little bit
morbid
a little bit uh
wrong about playing this video where you
know it's going to end in this man's
death and then the man is dead on the
video
so i'm not going to play but i will tell
you what happens i am i am giving you a
straight rundown if you want to check it
out for yourself you're more than
welcome to
cops come up knock on george floyd's
window he's sitting in his car
and he becomes very emotional and he
starts
sort of yelling and crying and anybody
crucially he isn't cooperating so
finally they get him to put his hands on
the
on the wheel but he seems like his
behavior is erratic
later it appears we found out he was on
drugs then they finally get him out
he says his mother just died that turned
out that was not true
his mother died a while ago then he says
that he he can't breathe this is why
he's standing up this is you know not
not while he's lying on the ground
then he refuses to get in the car he
says he says he won't get in the cop car
because he's claustrophobic he can't be
inside a car but obviously that's not
true because
when the cops arrested him first he was
sitting inside of a car
so very very strange behavior it's very
emotional to watch because
he's really he's crying he's he's
become erratic he's but
when you watch the whole footage you
think gosh this is horribly sad
and i don't know what happened here at
the end and i don't know why
you know the guy kept his knee on his
neck even when he wasn't moving and i
don't know any of these things
but overall what the footage shows
is that this was a much more complex
situation than anybody thought
the cops were not just going in and
trying to come out
and kill this guy there was a long issue
here there was a lot of erratic behavior
there was a lot of resisting arrest
it's going to make it very difficult for
this murder charge that they're trying
to throw on the cop to go through
you might say it was an abuse of power
you might say behaved inappropriately
might even say was manslaughter
but murder there's just not evidence of
that
but that's not going to get out i
guarantee you that video is going to be
suppressed if you can if you can even
find it still
that's not the point the reality is not
the point it's the illusion
and it's and it's the fact that you've
got to pay lip service to the
delusion and the fantasy and the
ideology and if you don't pay lip
service to it
you will have your life ruined all based
on a lie
this runs so deep you've got karen bass
now being considered as a potential vice
presidential candidate with joe biden
karen bass a radical who volunteered for
communists in the 70s
who praised fidel castro just a handful
of years ago
who regularly associates with the head
of black lives matter with
with self-described marxists then when i
asked her about it on television she
lied through her teeth and said she
didn't know any of those people
it's a radical person that could be his
running mate forget it even the staff
this culture has become so pervasive i
kid you not
a a comment on twitter by a scientist
a guy who runs a science journal a joke
about
round worms is now being denounced as
racist and sexist and promoting white
supremacy
seriously a guy michael eisen editor of
e-life
was talking about c elegans commonly
known as roundworms
he said they're the most overrated
animal they wiggle forward they wiggle
backwards
and occasionally they f themselves
that's it
it's pretty funny people were just
taking this joke in stride
and then a group actually came out and
said it was racist and it was sexist
how i don't know they were fine it was
basically following intersectionality to
its logical conclusion which is that
there's one oppressor group which i
guess would be straight white men who
think that they're men
and then everyone else is oppressed by
that group now apparently including
animals not just animals including
insects as well
not just insects including little round
worms so
one one person said look it's just a
joke and a woman replies it's just a
joke women
and people of color have heard that one
before that's how
locked up in this ideological fantasy
they are
that is a stifling environment that is
an environment
that is so ridiculous we would all be
laughing at it except you can't laugh at
it
because if you do laugh at it you could
lose everything
that that gives you a silent majority
whole job from now until the election
is not to appeal to left-wing democrats
it's not to appeal to left-wing interest
groups that the left has divvied up
it's not to pretend that he's a more
liberal candidate than joe biden which
is what his campaign was doing
inexplicably for months his entire
goal must be to appeal to that group
the silent majority of americans and an
environment as crazy as this
they just might vote for him that's our
show i'm michael moses the michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy bourie
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 20. you know the matte wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about
hope you'll give it a listen